if you have ever taken a trip to sun top
mountain in the mount baker snoqualmie
national forest washington state then
you may have come across an old wooden
structure the sun top fire lookout built
in the early 1930s the building was used
by the u.s forest service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby woodland at
one point sun top fire lookout would
have been manned
365 days a year complete with a bed for
staff who were stationed there on
rotation the single story lookout house
overlooks the scenic valleys of the
white river and huckleberry creek but
you're not here for an informative
tourist guide you probably don't care
about the frankly fascinating history of
the lookout and how it was used as part
of the aircraft warning service during
world war ii watching for enemy planes
no
you're here because something much
darker lurks inside the sun top fire
lookout and even though it appears to be
a simple one-story tall wooden structure
it certainly is not short on space
scp-3333 refers to an anomaly that the
foundation discovered inside the sun-top
fire lookout house the building's
interior is a single square room
measuring 14 feet by 14 feet with large
windows on all four sides when standing
inside sun top fire lookout looking up
at the wooden ceiling one will
immediately notice a trap door no big
deal right a lot of places have a
ceiling entrance to a small crawl space
there's probably nothing behind that
trap door apart from a dusty old attic
there's a latch that maybe once had a
padlock there but not anymore opening
the trapdoor will reveal a collapsible
ladder should anyone be brave or indeed
foolish enough to begin to climb then
they'll soon find themselves right back
where they started inside sun top fire
lookout or so it will seem the thing
about being in a place like the mount
baker snoqualmie national forest that
surrounds sun top fire lookout is that
woodland areas are teeming with life not
just plants and trees but birds and
other animals of the forest you can
never truly be alone in a setting like
that there is always life everywhere
around you so when you ascend the ladder
and climb right back into the sun top
fire lookout that is the first most
noticeable difference you will find it
may take a while at first but the
nagging absence of something unusually
so abundant in a forest will eventually
become obvious it's quiet
far too quiet no bird song or the sound
of distant calls from woodland critters
just silence
all around
anyone ascending the ladder will find
themselves in a copy of sun top fire
lookout's interior one story higher than
the ground level of the small wooden
building with the stairs leading up to
the front door getting taller each time
to reach up to the higher and higher
building now you know the scp foundation
and the types of bizarre
interdimensional anomalies that they're
used to dealing with perhaps
scp-3333 is a mirror dimension or a
plane of existence where sound doesn't
travel it certainly seems to be
identical to the sun top fire lookout
save for the lack of any organic life
outside of course it's what you'll find
living inside scp-3333
that you may want to worry about
climbing higher up the next ladder and
through the next trapdoor every time
with the same result you appear at
another copy of sun top fire lookout
each one higher up than the last what
first seemed to be an innocuous
unassuming wooden building is now an
endless ascension up into the heavens
towards the unknown in silence without a
shred of plant or animal life outside as
you climb perhaps you start to think
about how much higher these copies go
this might even be the biblical jacob's
ladder connecting heaven and earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
paradise it might make it worth the trip
but
scp-3333 is nothing that pleasant you
wouldn't be the first to attempt this
long climb when the scp foundation first
discovered scp-3333
a research detail set up an on-site base
camp to examine this spatial anomaly
their first exploration involves sending
a member of d-class personnel designated
d-4f68a up the ladder his d number is a
hexadecimal code that when translated to
text reads oh so we'll call him that for
brevity's sake during the first day's
exploration oh was able to climb 184
iterations of scp-3333
communicating with head researcher dr
williams below on the second day oh
could see a pair of figures standing
motionless on a nearby ridge but the
pair could not be seen by dr williams
and the other researchers at the base
camp both figures disappeared shortly
after o spotted them with the camera he
had been issued and he felt uneasy
almost certain that he saw them point at
him the next day at the 345th copy of
sun top fire lookout oh's behavior
started to noticeably change previously
he had been anxious about the long climb
and hadn't questioned directions given
to him by dr williams now he seemed to
speak more casually resisting
instructions asking williams to climb
back down and even calling her doc
instead of doctor oh also reported
seeing writing on the walls but there
was no evidence of this on his camera it
appeared that something had started to
affect him it was when o reached level
527 that things seemed to change more
dramatically rather than scp-3330
continuing upwards the copies of sun top
fire lookout no longer had a trap door
or ladder they seemed to be arranged
side by side in a grid-like pattern
stepping out of the main doorway oh
remarked on the lack of sunlight and a
walkway that connected directly to the
front door of the next iteration of
scp-3333
oh complained about the lack of natural
light and again requested to be allowed
back down dr williams instructed oh to
use the flashlights he was provided but
they wouldn't activate and their spare
batteries had vanished oh then noticed a
sudden movement and just then his
microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that
scp-3333 had something else lurking up
there dr williams oversaw the second
expedition into scp-3333
this time members of mobile task force
mod 0 also known by the code name
characteristic egg in spaces were sent
up the latter they were sent through the
various copies of sun top fire lookout
were not as eventful as os with no signs
of mysterious figures or anxious
feelings that oh seemed to feel as he
climbed when they reached level 527
where the copies of the lookouts stop
progressing upwards and spread out in a
pattern instead their lights and
equipment all seem to be in working
order however as the mtf team split up
one by one they encountered some sort of
anomaly or an effect of
scp-3333 that caused each of them to
vanish into the dark either that or
something took them these mtf units
reappeared confused and mod 5 the team's
leader graham purcell issued an order to
retreat and the entire squad went back
down the ladders for several days until
they finally reached the base camp again
the members of mod zero were adamant
they did not wish to climb
scp-3333 again but dr williams was
beginning to understand more of the
anomalies of facts it appeared to cause
abrupt changes to people's personalities
along with some sort of phenomenon that
caused things to appear and disappear
the higher one climb assuming these were
the result of a memetic effect dr
williams dispatched a counter-memetic
specialist for the next expedition this
specialist was a blind deaf and mute
woman known as a net or the null walker
who communicated via signaling system
embedded in her hand but was otherwise
immune to any memetic influences
observed by dr williams and graham
purcell at base camp annette made her
way to the top of scp-3333
reporting that she was aware of someone
watching her from outside the copies of
sun top fire lookout on her body camera
a flicker of motion occurred something
looking through the windows that ducked
out of frame when the camera passed in
its direction at the apex of scp-3333
annette kept her flashlight off but
reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as the ned switched on her
flashlight williams and purcell saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read mtf mod 5
graham purcell
the same man who was sitting next to dr
williams at base camp well the same man
on the outside at least the explanation
for everything going on inside scp-3333
all these strange occurrences and
disappearances finally came in a video
sent from dr williams's cell phone in it
a panicked williams covered in blood was
fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of scp-3333
there was no memetic effect at the apex
of the sun top fire lookout copies
nothing was causing the people that the
foundation sent up to act unlike
themselves they simply weren't
themselves anymore according to a
frantic video dr williams had discovered
the truth about what else was hiding
within
scp-3333 with just the right amount of
vagueness and intrigue the research team
had been drawn in it was as if they'd
been lured in by the lights of an
anglerfish realizing their grim fate
only too late the d-class o the mtf team
even annette had been replaced an
unknown group of entities on the top
level of
scp-3333 had been carefully observing
them waiting until they would not be
seen to slip in and switch places these
entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects like oh seeing figures
that weren't really there as a way of
luring more bodies further up the stack
they wanted the foundation to keep
sending expeditions into scp-3333
to keep them coming back the mass of
organs musculature and bones that
annette had stumbled across revealing
the ruse had once belonged 2 gram per
cell before he was replaced you see the
entities residing in
scp-3333 weren't just copying people
they weren't possessing them or mind
controlling them or even shape-shifting
to steal a person's likeness
they were taking skin these creatures
hollowed out graham oh annette and the
mtf team pulling out their innards and
crawling their way inside filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their
internal organs to rot these
hollowed-out people became vessels for
the entities of scp-3333
to haydn the whole thing had been a trap
intentionally exploiting human
weaknesses
intrigue and unanswered questions you
know what they say about curiosity and
these entities used it to bring more
potential vessels to the top of scp-3333
they pretended to be the people who they
had replaced imitating them so the
foundation would send more personnel to
explore the tower increasing their
supply of skins graham's dog tag had
revealed the deception and dr williams
had escaped up scp-3333
the members of the research team that
had already been replaced were hot on
her tail determined to catch and hollow
her out too and by the end of her video
they had succeeded a month later though
a team delivering supplies realized what
had happened and the trap door was
sealed sun top fire lookout was put
under permanent guard but at least 50
personnel were killed or replaced by one
of the entities a new mobile task force
lambda 1 maxwell's demons was created to
hunt down and neutralize any of the
entities that had escaped
scp-3333 but it's still unknown how many
left the tower and are still out there
somewhere waiting to use someone's
curiosity about the strange and unknown
against them now check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer and
scp-3999 i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me for more tales of
anomalous terror from scp explained